[Musique]
les etats-unis sont toujours à la pointe
du progrès cet étudiant américain qui
prépare une thèse sur les transports
miniature à réinventer la patinette pour
illustrer sa tête un repose-pied 4
roulettes un petit moteur voilà
peut-être comment sera équipé le piéton
de l'an 2000 c'est un peu encombrant
c'est simple et c'est économique de
livres aux 1000 km et voilà le problème
de la circulation résolu c'est également
un bon moyen pour ne pas user ses
chaussures voilà à quoi passe son temps
un étudiant américain on commence à
comprendre pourquoi certains savants
d'outre-atlantique s'inquiète du retard
que prennent les états unis dans la
conquête de l'espace interplanétaire
pendant ce temps notre étudiant es
content de lui il arrive le premier à
l'université avant tout c'est camara
[Musique]